welcome to this video yeah is this is a
new five-minute session yeah let's see
and what we can do okay and place my own
line in a way but they always are not
always but at the moment I like to play
against the Slovak we'd see two queen
bee three but okay the Bishop g4 line
and all that leads to pretty solid play
for black and he is taking a timeout
here quite quite early that's mostly
Knight c3 year all night BTW to John
okay Bishop g5 is a play will move of
course it's no no serious drawback okay
yeah black as usual can just set up a
normal and all the development here
Knight to e5 yeah okay I need to move
the bishop yeah you can do that but it
gives it just gives me the bishop pal
nothing that's nothing special for white
I mean
nothing to be particularly afraid of um
so what will he do now I can go III the
should be 3 jun Ji 3 does Queen d5 this
is immediately um yeah making g3
harmless the community five ok Knight f6
should better be should better be a B
fire BB fault okay okay so he's saying
he's not going to Castle anymore
basically i can go age five
h5 III my tongue bring the night back
again to our form interesting what is
doing is very slowly yes not developed
asking side at all I wonder no probably
this is too handsy f5 h5 f form that's
playable it's not particularly bad okay
I keep it keep it simple now be sure to
d6 basically asking the night what it is
doing on g3 yeah this this kind of moves
are necessary then now again trying to
destroy spawn structure so the night I
guess has to move but II too of course
clocks up the development even further
yeah this is move at AC 5v5 is one
possibility or play on the gphone if
I've is very direct down captain
should I should make some use of my
bishop him okay can take first on I
might have 94 and let take here no it's
not it's not a big problem is it 94 I
can still I can just take it if you
recaptures I'm going to casa long jack I
thought just Queenie seven should be
should be alright or is there something
great I don't I don't see it
between age 7 i'm going to casa long and
then I should be okay at least
yeah not sure what else I mean taking
only seven is certainly not leading to
anything for white if the moment is the
spawn down on a form that I captured so
we probably should should go Queen h7 or
is there something that i don't see hand
so very much possible
yeah okay after long castles check okay
check
yeah well this is certainly difficult to
do to play for a win here but it's it's
a nice position okay I go f six year to
to have ye 5i Scott Luke d3m this is
this is the problem will this will teach
you some substantial exchanges root dat
Scott rookie one check maybe King f king
f6 Luke f3 PO chai yeah it's very dry
roop d3 is giving him this big play on
the DFR after d3 it's very difficult not
to play up the aid and exchange of all
looks after which we have a totally
equal opposite colored bishops endgame
it's very easy to hold you will just put
in bishop on your three and then shuffle
with the King not but it's it's hard to
hard to avoid maybe I can avoid it but
Jack it's difficult it's very difficult
to do
the check here King is success also
Bishop c4 I mean okay yeah very little
to do here I can I can push the
queenside up attendant hope for the best
but that sets not so I don't really
understand to this why is he does not he
needs the King on the queenside that's
the way to draw okay if he is playing
some more funny moves I really have some
winning chances this is this is a very
bad defense interesting time morning
King c3 would be good okay Kings III is
better need to make sure that the king
is not returning I he went he is going
to the going to them King side with the
king is very very rare decision just
need to to stay on the queenside white
resign oh you lost this tote this
completely drawn endgame in in 30 moves
this is not so easy this this is just
totally wrong I mean here you what you
need to do is you need to distribute job
cm the the King side is no problem at
all white can just put put the bishop
let's say here this is awesome wasn't
good put the bishop on f3 and from a
free it protects both porn so the bishop
is completely making sure that there's
nothing happening
the King side and then you just stay on
c2 with the king and do nothing
absolutely nothing and the only thing
that black can do is I can I can push my
pawns all the way kinking hooking up
something but the king is just staying
there and you keep the pawns exactly
where they are you can't put it on b3 if
you want and it's nothing really that
it's not mattering really and at some
point I try to get a passport and this
passed pawn will be blocked on a light
square by the king so the king is making
sure that nothing happens on the
queenside and the bishop is holding the
Kings side and what he did is he ran
over to the Kings side which is really
unnecessary it's useless and then he
also went a 4 which is yeah it's the
only way to lose this game and here I
mean here absolutely you must go back
why go to f5 the King has has nothing to
do there it's it's useless if he if he
returns um is it is it a draw still like
he can go to he gets to see to its
probably it's probably still a draw if
we consider this yeah it's still a draw
of course still he can go to a 2 or get
stay on b1 porn a point coming to a 3 s
is blocked by the bishop on f7 he has
made life more deform it made his life
more difficult than necessary but it
still a draw but he went here and and
now I don't know this is this is
probably lost now the ISS lost this is
lost he cannot really catch the pawn a
very weird end gameplay ok thanks for
watching